I was doing well, but then I got a job
with the Library of Congress
dealing again with Middle Eastern Arabic
books and that field and that was an
amazing job. Before long it became a
full-time job. It was 40 hour week and
before long I also came across writings
in Arabic that were written by Osama bin
Laden and Ayman al-Zawahiri of al-Qaeda.
And this was still when al-Qaeda was big
news. I found these in 2004, so just a
few years after 2001. And what was
interesting about these writings in
Arabic is they were completely different
than what al-Qaeda had been sending
messages to the West saying. So
previously al-Qaeda's message was we
attacked you because you attacked us
first. It's all about reciprocal
treatment. You've done this, that, and
the other thing. Israel, you and Israel
are torturing everyone, colonialism, you
know, the Crusades, what you people have
done to us. So the whole narrative was
this big long grievance mantra, okay?
Even at one point he was complaining
that the US didn't sign on to the Kyoto
Protocol.
Believe it or not, about the
environment. Yeah.
>> Specific. Yeah, he actually mentioned
that. Um so that that those were the
messages that were being disseminated to
the West and the media Western media was
helping because they want to show you
what the other side is saying.
What I came across in Arabic though said
the exact opposite. It sounded more like
ISIS.
Because now he's talking to fellow
Muslims in Arabic not thinking no one no
infidel is going to be privy to this
information. And it was basically yeah,
we have to hate and war against them
because they're infidels. It has nothing
to do with what they do, whether they're
good or kind to us or bad or evil. We
have to subjugate them. So I got a book
deal of the Arabic thing because I
wanted to show
what al-Qaeda had been saying to Muslims
versus what they said to non-Muslims and
it came out in my first book The
al-Qaeda Reader, which was finally
published in 2007. That it very early on
initially struck me as an a perfect
example. I came from again a back
academic background studying history. So
I was very much interested in jihad and
Crusades, but when I came across the
al-Qaeda thing I believed originally
what they were saying, which is oh we're
doing this because you've done that. So
when I read in Arabic what they were
really saying and how they were
referencing history to solidify their
point and talking about yes, you know,
we are the nation of the jihad, etc.,
etc. I thought that that has stayed with
me really since from then to now and so
one of my writing missions is just to
show the continuity, the true
continuity,
between Islamic hostility for the West
past and present. And also all the many
lies that permeated past and present
because we have the same examples of
deception and lies and then all that
sort of thing going on. I want to on
that point cuz I I spoke last week at
the European Parliament about the
Islamification of Europe and an Imam was
there sort of giving the other side and
he said, "No, no, what infidels really
means and I'm sure you know where this
is going is it's just
sort of non-believers, but even atheists
are fine as well. So it's not actually
Christians and Jews and so on." I
imagine you'd dispute that. As far as
infidel it's funny because they they
come up with all these apologetics and I
think what he's trying to tell you is
the word infidel. Well, that's that's an
English word. It's not even necessarily
a good translation. I use it often. The
word is kafir in Arabic and it's true.
So So a kafir is a non-Muslim. You can
translate it as a non-Muslim, but that's
their way of trying to
make it hygienic. Because what it is is
is a non-Muslim, but the word is loaded
with so many pejoratives and evil
connotations. Okay? So by default to be
a non-Muslim based on this word is to be
an enemy.
Okay? So and maybe the other things that
they they play with is they'll call
Christians and Jews people of the book.
That's what he was angling at.
>> Right, ahl al-kitab, which is So if
you're ahl al-kitab, a people of the
book, yes, you are technically better to
be treated better than the kafir, but
it's not a whole lot better. The kafir
is you submit, convert to Islam, or die.
That's it. The Christian and the Jew is
submit, become Muslim, or fine, keep
your religion, pay tribute, and be a
second class citizen and or more like a
third class citizen if you really
understand it. So it's marginally
better, but
but the the war is to be waged on both
until they submit one way or the other.
The only difference is the Christian and
Jew has the right to maintain their
faith, but they are suppressed subjects.
Quran 9:29 is the key one, which says
fight the people of the book
until they until they pay tribute and
feel themselves humbled. So it's not
just about taking money from them. You
have to make sure that in the social
order that they are suppressed. And one
of the reasons for that is in the hopes
that eventually they convert. And they
did. That is actually the history of how
Islam spread. It would conquer regions,
let's say Egypt, my ancestral homeland,
or Syria. The vast majority of the
people there were actually Christians,
the overwhelming majority, with also a
lot of
Jews in Alexandria.
And so they had the right to pay
tribute, but before long people are have
no money. It's it's a demanding amount
of you know, tribute that they
And people get tired of being social
outcast. They they can't get jobs. They
are despised. They can't you know, so
they become Muslims. That's the true
story of the spread of Islam. And it's
actually understood that this jizya tax
based on that Quran is on the one hand
to show some leniency and on the other
hand it's kind of a we get money out of
you and then eventually you become a
Muslim.
>> [music]
>> Bring back
the fire
in the righteous
name.